hi there steve kaufman here
i'm back i'm back in vancouver after a
month
or more
uh and i want to talk about enjoying
language learning
and i'm going to talk about how it
affects me personally uh new year we're
thinking of new year's resolutions
uh i've always wanted to learn arabic
farsi turkish i kind of want to get into
that
you know middle east central asian part
of the world that i don't really know
much about and so i in fact i took with
me a book of uh you know how to learn
the arabic alphabet and stuff
and you know what i just haven't got the
motivation to be perfectly honest and
what's
the what is pulling me back is not my
lack of interest in those languages but
rather the fact that i want to enjoy now
this year the languages that i have
already learned because
you know my korean isn't where i wanted
to be obviously my polish isn't where i
want it to be i want to work on other
languages because i enjoy the languages
so
obviously that initial period when
you're breaking into a new language is a
lot of hard work
and
it's like you know initially planting
your garden but now i'm at the stage
where i want to enjoy
uh the fruits of my labor more so
i recently i've been doing more
ukrainian i had a couple of
conversations in ukrainian
i'm going to go back to my korean so
this year is going to be a year of
consolidation
and
arabic and farsi and
you know hindi or whatever is going to
have to wait until next year and we'll
see what happens next year but i think
it's very important unless you know you
have to learn the language for an exam
or you have to learn it for your work
but for many language learners and
certainly in my case i learn languages
for enjoyment and i love doing it so why
would i put pressure on myself when you
know that motivation motivation that
strong motivation
isn't there it will come and when i do
have that strong motivation i will claw
my way through the difficulties of the
arabic writing system and
dealing with a brand new language and
get it to a point where i can actually
start enjoying
uh learning it but i've done that now
for polish i've done it for ukrainian
i've done for korean and now i have the
opportunity to go in there and enjoy my
reading and listening and eventually
talking to people and watching movies
and stuff so this year i'm devoting to
enjoying the languages that i have
already
engaged with so that's my kind of new
year's position on languages for this
year thank you for listening bye for now